[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live.
I'm Louis Gray here with Google
Developers Live from
Mountain View, California
at Google headquarters.
I have a great guess with me for
the second day in a row,
Brian Fitzpatrick, coming here
to talk to us about Data
Liberation and the Data
Liberation Front all the way
from sunny Chicago, Illinois.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: It's
very sunny right now,
as a matter of fact.
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome, Fitz.
It's always good to
have you around.
And I know from my time prior
to joining Google, we got to
talk a lot about the work that
you're doing in this really,
kind of, unique and individual
project with Data Liberation.
We often talk a lot about new
products that are coming out
and new features that are
getting rolled out.
But then the users go
ahead and use that.
And they put in a little
bit of data.
And usually, that's the
end of the story.
And you've done something
completely different, which is
talking about getting
that data out.
And so I want to really
start at the very top.
Let's talk about Data Liberation
Front, where are
you coming at with this, and
what can users do to
get their data out?
Why is this important?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well,
I want to answer
the important question.
I think it's important more than
anything because it's the
data you put into your products
and the data that you
create into products in any
company that's holding your
data for you, it's
stated, that you
should be able to control.
You should be able
to put it in.
to take it out.
And you should be able
to delete it.
And that's the basic argument.
The interesting thing is that I
found, when we were talking
about starting the Data
Liberation Front, that many
companies, Google included,
would make it, I would say,
possible for you to take
your data out.
But it wasn't always easy.
So our thought was, instead of
doing public relations to say,
yes, you can get your data out
and it's easy when it really
wasn't, that, as an engineering
company, we could
actually build products.
And make engineering changes
to make it easy for you to
take your data out.
LOUIS GRAY: And what are
those kinds of changes?
I know from having used this
product myself, you have
essentially centralized one
place for me to get my data
out from multiple services.
Is that right?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Correct.
Google Takeout is where
we are today.
But we first started this
project, internally, back in
2007, which seems like a long,
long time ago now.
And we, basically, put together
a small team of
engineers to go from product to
product and say, hey, have
you ever considered making
it easy for users to
export their data?
And everyone would
say, oh, yeah.
We've been thinking about it.
It's been on our roadmap
since, like, 1993.
But it's really low priority
because we've got a lot of
other stuff we're
trying to do.
And people aren't beating the
door down asking leave.
LOUIS GRAY: That's a good
thing that they're
not trying to leave.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: It
is a good thing.
But I said, what if we come
in and help you do the
[INAUDIBLE].
What if we did the work
with your team?
Just parachute in and,
actually, do
the engineering work.
And every one was like, oh, this
is the best thing ever.
Please, come right in.
You know?
Have a cup of coffee.
So we started doing that.
We went from product
to product.
It was, actually, Notebook and
iGoogle, which were the first
things before we warmed up to
Blogger, which was the big
first project we did.
And as we started doing this,
the team started to realize
that this was just intractable
because Google was adding new
products at the time.
And we had these, sort of,
three questions to
ask with your data.
Can I get it out?
How long is it going to
take to get it out?
And how much is it
going to cost?
And we realized that the
how long was just
continuing to go linearly.
Every time we had a product,
that means one more thing you
have to go download.
So being engineers, my
team was like this
doesn't seem right.
I said, well, what would
you like to do?
If you could do anything you
want, what would you guys do?
And they went off, and they
came back to me two weeks
later and said we want to
create this thing, which
turned out to be Takeout, where
you can go and get all
your data at one place.
Just click and get all your data
for all Google products.
Now we're still working
on getting some
products, to be clear.
But I'm like, that sound
suitably insane.
Let's make it happen.
So they started working
on that a while back.
And we launched that the same
day Google+ launched in 2011.
And over the course of
the past to years--
LOUIS GRAY: I bet that
was a big day.
I mean, not working at Google
at that time trying to cover
all the news that
was coming out.
I know we did a Hangout talking
about the Google
Takeout project that
[INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
That's right.
That was one of the first
Hangout press interviews ever.
LOUIS GRAY: And we had
a dedicated circle.
And those of us dialed in from
our homes, where we were, and
learned about it.
And there was a lot to
cover at that time.
You're talking about bringing
your data and moving along
from project to project and
product to product.
As someone who's been using the
internet for some time,
you and I, probably, have
accumulated our own history of
number of email addresses
and number of email
clients that we've had.
And prior to Gmail, most of
these were like software.
So I've been one of those guys
that's, kind of, been an email
hoarder and moved it from
Eudora over to Microsoft
Outlook Express.
And maybe back to Apple Mail and
then back over to Gmail.
So we've always thought there
was that capability where you
could export it and then
move it along.
But that doesn't seem
to be the way that
most software works.
And maybe I'm one of those odd
people who doesn't abandon my
10 year ago email.
What kind of data do you think
is the thing that people
export the most?
What is the most valuable to
them to get a hold of?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, first
of all, I'd like to say that
I've got all my email,
since 1995, in Gmail.
And I actually went through,
recently, in search for
something that came from 1996.
So it's pretty awesome
to have that around.
LOUIS GRAY: That's a
lot of gigs, Fitz.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Actually,
it's not that much because,
back in the '90s, people
didn't mail
anything around but text.
Like, I didn't get pictures
and movies and
crazy things like that.
LOUIS GRAY: Attachments that you
would send could take the
company server down.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Yeah, exactly.
So you never wanted to like--
and people had limits on their
signatures.
You remember?
Like, anything more than
four lines, someone
would yell at you.
Yeah, but the most valuable
things tend to be things that
people don't consider as data.
Like, I think contacts are very
valuable, for one thing,
because it's your way of
getting a hold of your
friends, and family, and
that sort of thing.
But the most valuable one that
I see, really, is photos
because photos are very
emotional things.
The example that I tell people
when I meet someone new and
they say, what do
you at Google?
Do you work on the doodles
with the Pac-Man thing?
And they say, oh,
that's great.
And I said, no, I don't
work on that.
And they're just like,
I'm not interested.
But I say, what I work
on is this Data
Liberation Front thing.
And if they're not a technical
person, they're like
[SNORING SOUND]
because this is boring
to them.
Why should they care
about data?
LOUIS GRAY: It's boring until
they really want it.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Not only
that, but it's boring until I
say, look, at home do you have
a shoe box full of old photos
and letters from your
grandparents
from back in the day?
And they're usually like yeah.
It's up in a closet.
It's not very useful to me.
I said, you don't share
it with folks.
You can't look at it very easily
and leaf through it and
search through it.
But if that disappeared, you'd
probably be pretty upset.
And [INAUDIBLE] says,
of course.
This is very emotional
and very valuable.
I said, it's the same thing
with the data that you're
creating in your blog, or
Google+, or your photos, or
any of this type of stuff.
So I really encourage people to
think of their data not as
a bunch of ones and zeroes but
as something that is your
digital legacy.
It's that shoe box but in a much
more useful fashion and
stored on the internet.
And we're, sort of, custodians
of that data.
We need to make sure that we
don't lose it, for one.
But we also need to make sure
that you could take a copy of
it with you if you want to go
somewhere else, or try a
different product somewhere, or
just have another copy at
home for peace of mind
because disk
storage is so cheap nowadays.
LOUIS GRAY: One of the
interesting things you have,
from an engineering perspective,
is the challenge
itself of picking the correct
standard and making sure it
sticks around for a while.
I remember from your
introductory video that's
quite famous, you walk through
the zip drives, and the beta
disks, and DVDs, and the CDs.
And over time, some of these
places where we used to store
data start to seem quaint.
Who really carries these
floppy disks around?
So how do you approach a problem
like that, from the
technology perspective, and say
all of these photos that
you're going to be able to
export from be it Picasa or
Google+ Photos or somewhere?
What's the right standard
to choose?
How do you know that it's going
to be good to export?
And, possibly, good to import
somewhere else?
And does that ever change?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
It does change.
Standards change all the time.
And the interesting thing
about standards is that
there's so many to
choose from.
That's the, sort
of, old adage.
But our baseline is
for exporters.
We choose open standards that
are not encumbered by patents
that are as simple as possible
so that engineers, like the
team that works on Data
Liberation Front, can easily
write a program that could parse
it, put it into another
product, and transform
it in some fashion.
The interesting thing is that
when you have data on your
laptop, like you used to years
ago, you have a Chromebook,
which is an amazing
piece of hardware.
LOUIS GRAY: This pixel has maybe
two megs of content,
locally, on my hard drive
because I never need to do it.
It's like transitory.
If I'm going to take it down,
I'm going to put it right back
up in the cloud and that's it.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: It's To extra
copy, typically, but
it's all stored in the cloud.
But in the old days, when you
have something in your laptop
and formats would change,
you'd be stuck behind.
You'd have to find a
translation program or something.
On my laptop, I have an old Word
Processor file from 1995.
There's no Word Processor
available to open that file.
And it's an actual valid
file, as far as I know.
It's just that the file format
has gone the way of the dodos.
LOUIS GRAY: To the data
standard graveyard.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: To the data
center graveyard, yes.
And the interesting thing about
that is that if Google
has all your data, or some
other company online is
storing data for many,
many people.
We can run a program over all
that and change from format to
format, in many cases,
losslessly.
So as new formats
come into play--
I think YouTube is as
an example of this.
Right?
They can transcode your videos
from mobile to be much more
bandwidth effective
or much less
inefficient using bandwidth.
They can transcode things
for lower resolution,
that kind of thing.
But they still got the
original there.
And in fact, when YouTube went
into Takeout, we made sure you
could get your original copy so
you're not losing any data
there at all.
LOUIS GRAY: We're broadcasting
on YouTube right now.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Really?
LOUIS GRAY: I don't know
if you knew that.
It's happening--
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
This is awesome.
LOUIS GRAY: --right
now this second.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
The future's now.
LOUIS GRAY: One of the cool
things about broadcasting on
YouTube is you have the live
version, and then you have the
archive copy, which people can
go in later and, as you
mentioned, you can
download it.
And if you're somebody who's
really good with software, you
can just make a edit
and put it back up.
One of things I was
thinking of--
I get this question a lot when
we're talking about Google,
and I think we mentioned a
little bit yesterday when we
were discussing organizational
manipulation--
is altruism.
People tend to not trust
companies that provide
software or services.
And they're wondering, why is
it that you're providing me
with this service?
Why do you want me to
get my data out?
Don't you care about the
customer being locked in?
Don't you want to have
more user data?
Like, what's your deal?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: I disagree
with your first statement.
I think people don't trust
companies period because why
should they?
The reputation and if you look
at past performance, I think
many companies have done things
that have shown users
that we're not to be trusted.
And I don't think that Google
is doing any of this data
liberation stuff.
We'll talk about transparency
tomorrow.
None of this is because we're
nice people or altruistic.
Although, I think you and I,
at least, are nice people.
LOUIS GRAY: That's two down.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Yeah, exactly.
Two down.
Several 10,000 to go.
But really it's because it's
good for business long term.
And I think Google has managed
to tie its' success with the
success of the internet.
And it's a very consumer
friendly attitude.
So many times it may look like
we're doing this Data
Liberation thing for altruism.
But honestly, it's by focusing
on keeping users by
engineering innovation.
Making our products better and
making our products faster.
I think that it's a better way
to compete and a better way to
keep our users.
For example, I ask people all
the time who are at Google who
ask me why we're doing this
Data Liberation thing.
I say, well, do you
use Google search?
And, most of the time,
they'll say yes.
I'll say, did you buy
a two year contract
to use Google search?
They're like, no.
I'm like, did you buy a piece
of hardware that only works
with Google search?
And they'll say no.
Of course not.
I use my browser.
I can go to Bing.com
if I want to.
All right, well, why are you
still using Google search?
And their response usually is,
well, it finds what I want and
gets out of my way.
It's the best product
for my needs.
And my argument is that
all of our products
should be that way.
If Blogger isn't the best
product for needs, then you
should be able to take your data
and go use WordPress, or
TypePad, or something
like that.
Same goes for photos.
Same goes for your G+ stream.
That sort of thing.
LOUIS GRAY: So you think, maybe,
it puts a little bit of
pressure on the services that
we provide to get better and
make sure that we're maintained
as being the best.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I
think it's partly that.
But I think part of it is the
fact that, if you lock your
users in, your product can be
dying in the vine and you're
not even going to know it
because the users will reach a
point we're they'll just leave
without their data.
And the interesting thing
about us is we
have a lot of products.
So if you decide you want to
leave one of our products
today because you found a better
product to meet your
needs, I would argue that that
experience with leaving has to
be a good experience for you.
Otherwise, we're not going to
get you to come back next
week, or tomorrow, or
the month after
to try a new product.
And I think the fact that we're
on the internet where
it's super easy to try new
products and super easy to
switch, I think trust is more
important than it was years
ago when you would have to go
to the store and get a box
with a diskette in it or a
bunch of diskettes in it.
And come home and install
it and reboot.
Then neighbor kid comes over
and tells you you got the
wrong software and you have
to go back to the store.
LOUIS GRAY: Hopefully,
they do returns
without too much damage.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: But they
don't because it's a shrink
wrap EULA, right?
We're in a different place.
Most software on the web you can
try for either a reduced
functionality version or for a
limited period of time and see
if you like it.
And if you like it, then you go
ahead and you use it or you
buy it whether it's ad driven
or you pay a subscription.
So there's a lot of, I think,
things that have changed in
the past 15 years that mean that
that trust is important.
And I think that's one
of the most valuable
things that we have.
And I think Data Liberation is
a way of protecting that.
LOUIS GRAY: Now, you
talked about
this at the very beginning.
The initials sell, I guess, for
the Data Liberation Front,
you had to go product to
product, person to person, and
say I have this idea.
How can I help you?
Is that still the case?
I mean, the Data Liberation
Front, you say
you started in '07.
I think it was announced
in '09.
Takeout was introduced
in 2011.
So it's been around
for a while.
How do you go about going to the
next product and trying to
make a case?
Is it harder now?
Is it easier now?
When Google products are made do
they have Takeout in mind?
Or is it still, kind of, going
back to the start?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: It's
a lot easier now.
I mean, it's a lot easier now
because, internally, Googlers
have seen the value, the
benefit, that the user trust
that their products get from
having Takeout integration.
So, typically, what happened
nowadays is a product, either
an existing product or one that
hasn't launched yet, will
come to us and say, hey, we
want to be in Takeout.
And we have a little integration
document that's
super straightforward
and very simple.
And we've refined it over the
years to make sure that it's,
actually, easy to follow, that
they can go ahead and
implement the following little
bit of API, and then do a last
little time with us.
And it's, relatively,
straightforward to make it
easy for us to put your
data into Takeout.
So a lot of products come
directly to us and say, hey,
we want to do this.
In some cases, some products
ask us for help.
In some cases, we go and say,
hey, we'd like to have your
product in Takeout.
But we're very selective about
the ones that we go after.
But it's never a fight.
It's always like, hey,
this is great.
Thank you guys for
helping us out.
LOUIS GRAY: And do you ever find
that it's kind of like a
user swell?
Like, if persons one through one
million say I want to get
my data out of product x, does
that help your push?
And say I need to go and extract
more data out of, say,
G+ or Chrome, or one of the
other supported services?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: I don't think
there's ever been that
little problem.
I think the push the really hard
pushes always come from
myself and the team itself.
They always want it
to be better.
I mean, the team of engineers
I have working at Data
Liberation are some of the
finest engineers I've ever
worked with.
They've got to dive into parts
of Googles and code base
across the board.
And it's a real challenge just
from a systems point of view.
They're dealing with lots
of data, in some cases.
YouTube, for example.
Those videos can get very big.
They're dealing with lots of
smaller files in other cases.
And they're dealing with,
basically, securely
authenticating across systems.
We can't just go and
grab your data.
We need to make sure that
we're passing your
authentication along the way.
And we securely get it so we
can never look at it at any
point or anything like that.
LOUIS GRAY: You brought
up something that's an
interesting point.
You were talking about
the pixel.
And I've transitioned to
being full Chrome OS.
I've been that way
for, probably, a
year and a half now.
But what's interesting with me
is I don't have a shoe box in
the closet.
What I have are old laptops.
So I've got a Mac that I stopped
using when I changed
jobs in '09.
I've got a Mac that I used
from '09 to 2011.
I've got the Mac I got when
I started working here.
And then I've got the pixel.
So I, kind of, have a slice
of time in my own
history of my data.
Like, here are the photos of
when my kids were two to four.
Here's photos when my kids
were four to five.
And what I've done is taken a
lot of work to get it all into
the cloud and get
it protected.
And when you start to think
about that as a service owner
or a service manipulator, going
back to yesterday, how
much additional pressure is it
to get that right when the
cloud starts to take up an
increasing percentage of
user's data so that you know
they, probably, don't have a
local copy anymore.
How much more challenging is it
to make sure you've got the
right standards and that we
don't delete anything?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, I think
it's always a challenge
to make sure that we never
lose any data.
That would be horrible.
That's a big trust issue.
And that's why, a lot of the
times, we talk about the fact
that we store multiple copies
across multiple physical
locations in case the data
center over here
gets hit by a meteor.
We want to make sure that your
data's still available to you
immediately because people
have an expectation.
They go to look to show their
child's photo to someone else
and it says, I'm sorry, your
data center's down for
maintenance or something.
That would be very awful.
So I think there's a huge
pressure to that.
But the one thing I tell anyone
that I talk to is
please have multiple copies
of your data.
If you have a copy in Google,
you should make a backup copy
to have on a home server, or a
home laptop, or somewhere.
Or take that copy and push
it up somewhere else.
But you should always have
multiple copies of your data.
I can't tell you how many
stories I've heard from
people, many of them my friends,
who have lost every
picture of their kids.
One of my friends lost every
picture of her son from birth
to age three because it
was all in one laptop
that she got stolen.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
And what if [INAUDIBLE]
crashed or one got stolen?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Yeah, that
scares the heck out of me.
It's horrifying.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah.
So pleasant.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: I'm
here to scare you.
LOUIS GRAY: Every conversation
we're like, ooh, better make
it happy at the end.
So when we download this
data, what services
let you import it?
Sometimes we talk about is
Google the only company that
can provide a service
like this.
And we can answer that
question, as well.
But if I take my data out of
Google, is it really easy to
get it into other places and
other equivalent networks.
Do they have the ability to have
an import tool that's as
good as our export?
Or is it still a challenge?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
I think it's a
chicken in an egg issue.
But I think if the data's not
available you're never going
to get the import parts done.
But there's some examples,
which are
very easy, like photos.
You pull out your photos and
you get a bunch of JPEGs or
whatever the heck photo format
your photo was initially in.
And it's easy to take those and
put them up anywhere else,
I would say.
In contacts, for example, the
contact import is very
straightforward. vCards
and calendars are very
straightforward with
iCal format.
Documents, spreadsheets, word
processor documents,
spreadsheets, and those
type of things.
We give you a couple
of choices.
If you want to stick with the
open formats, you can use the
open office formats.
If you're working with folks who
use Microsoft Office, you
can choose the Microsoft
Office formats.
So those are the typical
easy examples.
It gets a little harder when
there's not a defined standard
for moving data from one
system to another.
For example, Blogger.
There's no blog format.
So what we do is we create
a simple atom feed.
We've documented the
format publicly.
We have created an open
source project.
I believe it's called Google
Blog Converters, and you can
find that on Google Code.
And that is a reference
implementation that will
translate our format into
WordPress, and TypePad, and
maybe something else and back.
And that's under the
Apache license.
So any developer at any other
company can take that and say
look at this.
Say, oh, this is
how this works.
This is how we parse this
document format.
And this is how we can
put it in our format.
So that's there and
that's available.
I'm not sure who have made
use of it or not yet.
But that is, I think, the
solution to dealing with
formats where there's no real
web standard for them.
But we are using an
ad hoc standard to
a simple XML container.
LOUIS GRAY: And what are the
kind of services today that
are supported by Data
Liberation Front?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Wow.
Well, Takeout's got a
ton of stuff in it.
I mean, we initially launched
with social services.
So it was photos, it was your
contacts, it was your circles,
you're G+ stream, and probably
something else.
And then, pretty quickly after
that, we added Google Voice.
Then we added Google Drive,
which is Docs and
spreadsheets.
And we just continue to add
things to it over time.
So we've got YouTube and dozens
of other products.
And we're still working
on adding a last few.
So my team won't rest until
everything's in
there, pretty much.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
You got more to go.
Now, you introduced
something as a
little bit of a deviation.
Earlier this year, you talked
about legacy account
management.
And for those who are
unfamiliar, we
can talk about that.
But that's, essentially, if your
account is closed or if
you pass on, that your data
becomes available to someone
who you've designated it to.
Is that correct?
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: That's
an inactivity manager.
Correct, yes.
We worked with a team to provide
that if you don't
login to Google for a specified
period of time--
I think the minimum is three or
six months up to a year--
you can say notify this person
and give them access to these
pieces of my data as opposed to
leaving somebody your user
name and your password.
This way you could just say, if
I don't log into Google for
six months and something
happens, delete all my email
but give all my photos
to so and so.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's another
way we're utilizing the same
kind of back up, the same kind
of take out, and the same kind
of open standards could be
reused for a new way to help
the people out there.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Absolutely.
In fact, that uses the same
exact sort of systems that
Takeout works on.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
So what else can you tell our
viewers when they take a look
at Data Liberation Front?
What should they be thinking
about when it comes to,
either, putting their
data into a service
or taking it out?
You said there's, really,
three steps.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Well, yes.
So there's three questions that
you should ask before
using any software application
that's storing data for you.
And the first question, I think,
is the obvious one.
It's can I get my data
out in open format?
And that's, sort of,
like table stakes.
If the answer to that is no,
then I'm out of here.
Or if I do use your product, I'm
going to be very careful
about what I put in it because
I know it's locked up.
The second question is, what
does it cost me to get it out.
And that answer should
always be nothing.
So if it's a free service,
it should be free to
get your data out.
If your service costs $20 a
year or $50 a year, that
should include export
of your data.
And the third question,
I think, is more
of the tricky one.
It's how much of my time does
it take to get my data out?
And the example I gave
here is photos.
And this is where PR
often solved these
problems in the past.
Someone would say,
hey, can I get my
photos out of this product.
And the PR answers, well,
of course you can.
This is open and it's free.
And you, basically,
go to the photo.
And you click Save download,
Save As, go to
Desktop, and hit OK.
LOUIS GRAY: 2,000 times.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
Yeah 2,000 times.
Or 5,000 or 10,000 times.
So take a week off of work and
click your mouse button.
LOUIS GRAY: Just do a
right-click, Save As, repeat
168,000 times, and you're
in a good spot.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: Right.
So this is why you
should have--
I just hate to say one click--
a minimal amount of numbers.
The amount of data you have
shouldn't correspondent to the
amount of time it takes you
to get that data out.
So I think those are
the three things
that are most important.
And those are the things that
I think about before I start
using any online service because
often say, oh, this
stuff doesn't matter to me.
LOUIS GRAY: It's trivial.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: My stream
isn't important.
It's trivial.
My tweets aren't important.
But the interesting thing is
that there's no way to know
today what's important
in the future.
I look back to the emails that
I wrote back in the mid '90s
and I'm like, gosh,
these are dumb.
But it's like it's really neat
because I found early emails
that my wife and I said back and
forth when we were dating
and early messages with some
of my friends from college.
And it's messages with one
of my friends who died a
couple years ago.
And it's like, suddenly, this
stuff is valuable to me.
If you'd ask me at the time,
I be like, oh, no.
But I'm just a digital pack
rat, so I keep everything.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
I think everybody has
a story like that.
You talk about those types of
emails and it, kind of, jogged
a memory with me.
My wife and I were dating, and
we were trading emails
constantly.
And somehow in a blitz, I lost
several months worth of that.
And so we go from dating, and
the next thing you know we're
planning the wedding.
I missed all the stuff
in between.
I don't remember if I
said anything cool.
Like, what was it?
It's gone.
[LAUGHING]
LOUIS GRAY: Probably
nothing cool.
But it would be good to have
that back some time.
And I'm glad, at least,
we're doing this.
So Fitz, thank you so much
for coming back in.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK:
My pleasure.
LOUIS GRAY: I definitely want
people who are curious about
this to take a look at
dataliberation.org.
It's still free to log in.
Free to check it out.
And that is the Data
Liberation Front.
So Fitz, I know we're going to
be back here tomorrow here in
Mountain View before you
fly back to Chicago.
BRIAN FITZPATRICK: One more
day and you throw me out.
LOUIS GRAY: That's right.
That's all we can get.
But thank you very much for
checking in at Google
Developers Live.
I'm Louis Gray, and we'll
see you in the studio.
[MUSIC PLAYING]